es ist eine ganz große party
hunderttausende feiern wenn der nikolaus
kommt für amsterdam so etwas wie der
karneval für rio alle jahre wieder heißt
der mann mit dem weißen bart per boot
von spanien in die niederlande
so sagt es die legende mit dabei hatte
er seine helfer die zweite bieten die
schwarzen peter
die figur ist der liebling der kinder
der clown der die süßigkeiten verteilt
auch wenn der zauber schnell verfliegt
ja als ich noch klein war habe ich an
nikolaus geklaut aber heute weiß ich
dass er nicht wirklich echt ist und
stelle ich mir jedes mal meine stiefel
aus eine expertengruppe der vereinten
nationen stößt sich nicht am nikolaus
sondern an seinen begleitern die
schwarzen peter seien rassistisch ein
überbleibsel der sklaverei
sie passt nicht in ein politisch
korrektes klima und sollten weg das ist
doch mist
warum
und das ist tradition und das sehen die
schwarzen von den inseln genauso wie die
weißen den kindern ist es egal ob sie
schwarz farbig oder weiß sind sie sie
nicht den unterschied das ist nur eine
party bei der sie am ende geschenke
bekommen nicht alle niederländer sehen
das so entspannt vor dem einmarsch des
nikolaus protest gegen den schwarzen
peter
die demonstranten sehen in der figur
einer diskriminierung der schwarzen
bürger der künstler kven zigarillo
reichte deshalb klage beim europäischen
gerichtshof für menschenrechte ein
in dieser seitenstraße hat dario eine
wöchentliche talkshow hier sendet die
multikulti station nord eigentlich geht
es heute um mode doch über die hinter
glas parade muss cario auch reden
der schwarze peter ist eng verbunden mit
unserer kolonialgeschichte
er tauchte das erste mal zwischen 1828
und 1851 auf er präsentiert einen
schwarzen körper als gegenstand etwas
das seine menschlichkeit verloren hat
und der bloßen unterhaltung dient im
mertens institut für holländische
geschichte rauchen den wissenschaftlern
die köpfe wie war das doch gleich noch
mal mit dem heiligen nikolaus und seinem
schwarzen peter auf alten abbildungen
ist er als diener zu sehen außerdem muss
er in dieser rolle unartige kinder
bestrafen
das sei sicher rassistisch aber
vergangenheit
der charakter des schwarzen peters hat
sich verändert
er ist nicht mehr das monster das kinder
verschreckt oder sie in einem sack nach
spanien verschleppt
er ist jetzt eine gute figur denn den
niederländern ist über die jahrzehnte
klar geworden dass es schwierig ist wenn
eine schwarze person sich wie ein
monster aufhört doch weil der protest in
diesem jahr so massiv ist zeigen die
organisatoren dass sie zu weiteren
veränderungen bereit sind
so trägt der schwarze peter keine
goldenen ohrringe mehr
vor allem dieses accessoire so die
befürchtung könnte ihn wie einen sklaven
aussehen lassen
mario rossi weiters findet das weglassen
der ohrringe gut aber die einmischung
der uno hält sie für übertrieben
die ärztin ist ein wahrer nikolaus fan
sie hat sogar ein lexikon rund um ihn
geschrieben und sie kann nachvollziehen
dass viele niederländer fürchten dass
ihnen ihre geliebte tradition abhanden
kommt die niederländer sind eng mit
ihrem fest verbunden und sie wollen
nicht dass irgendjemand ihnen sagt dass
sie es so nicht mehr feiern sollten es
recht wenn es sich dabei um fremde
handelt es ist wie bei den spaniern und
ihren stil kämpft auch sie wohl nicht
von außerhalb hören dass sie das so
nicht mehr tun sollten
doch auf den straßen von amsterdam es
der pikon seltener zu finden wo er noch
vor einem jahr in der lichterkette hing
fehlt er nun für die anti zwarte piet
bewegung ein kleiner erfolg
die befürworter des nikolaus helfers
finden aber auch jede menge zuspruch pc
heißt ihre facebook-seite ein wortspiel
eine mischung aus beat und petition
sie hat mehr als zwei millionen likes
man kann lesen wir wollen unseren
schwarzen peter behalten wer ihn nicht
will soll auch selbst gehen manche
fürchten sogar dass mit der debatte den
rechtspopulisten regelrecht unterstützer
in die arme getrieben werden
das ist nicht mein fehler oder der feder
der opfer von rassismus das ist der
fehler eines bildungssystems das den
menschen hier vermittelt sie seien
besser als der rest der welt
der nikolaus steigt am 6 dezember wieder
auf sein boot das sie nach spanien
bringt bleiben wird der protest gegen
den schwarzen peter
er kommt jetzt erst richtig in fahrt